the media in the digital age new
freedoms or new restraints in the
interview the political critic Noam
Chomsky former CIA and NSA intelligence
contractor Edward Snowden has blown the
whistle on one of the biggest data
scandals of all time Snowden leaked
details of wide-scale internet
surveillance by US and British
intelligence agencies US President
Barack Obama defended the NSA's prism
surveillance program as a legitimate
means in the fight against terrorism
Noam Chomsky criticizes the logic behind
obama's justification for spying on the
internet but Chomsky also believes that
the new media offers new opportunities
he's been criticizing traditional media
as the mouthpiece of political and
financial elites for more than 20 years
saying they work to manufacture consent
I'm very interested to know to what
extent you believe that the new medium
also manufacture consent with elites or
perhaps on the other hand make dissent
possible enabled dissent where's the
balance and the internet is it's a new
tool that actually developed in the
state sector of the economy for about 30
years and was then mid-90s handed over
to private enterprise for
commercialization and like other tools
it's fundamentally neutral like like a
hammer say the hammer doesn't care
whether a torturer uses it to bash
someone's skull in or carpenter uses it
to build a house and it's the same with
the internet but that the fundamentally
neutral tool that you have been
describing has of course being used in
large measure in the the two greats
uprisings that we've seen in the last
several years which are occupy and the
Arab Spring so social media have played
a very what I'm sure you must see that's
a very progressive role they have that
role but as I said a hammer can build a
house and the print media also had that
role now the internet does give you much
wider possibilities and it was hoped by
many including me
would lead to broadening of horizons a
search for independent sources and so on
I have never seen a study but i think
it's had the opposite effect overall
it's probably led to focusing people
more narrowly on a specific often
cult-like commitment to some point of
view they know what they're already
looking for they look they know what
they're looking for and they go for that
and you get a self fortifying cycle of
more and more extremism more and more
cult-like behavior more and more
inability or unwillingness to consider
broader or alternative points of view
it's had that effect two okay point
taken let's talk about the Arab Spring
let's talk about Occupy you've been
viewed as one of the intellectual
fathers of the Occupy movement I know a
lot of our viewers would be very
interested to know how you compare
occupy and indeed the Arab Spring with
the with the American Civil Rights
Movement the counterculture movement of
the of the u.s. in the 1960s somewhat
different the first wasn't one of the
intellectual founders of was an observer
if I'd been asked a month before in an
inspiration well could talk about that
but I've been a sympathetic observer and
partial participant and I've been very
happy to see it I it's I certainly
wouldn't have predicted it if I'd been
asked I would have said it's a crazy
idea but it lit a spark the Zuccotti
Park occupation very quickly spread in
no time there were hundreds of similar
occupations in the United States broad
Australia England everywhere it linked
up with similar movements already
existing in Europe like the indignados
and Spain and so on it was connected to
the Arab Spring and there was a mutual
interaction so there were solidarity a
message is coming from the Egyptian
labor movement
her squared to the American organizers
both in Wisconsin and Zuccotti and so on
and conversely in fact just last week
was it there was a unoccupied
demonstration in New York in solidarity
with ongoing demonstrations at the same
time let me just interrupt for a second
because it's interesting that you say
that talker you talk with that immediacy
about events because you'd you talk
about the Occupy movement as lighting a
spark but there are a lot of political
commentators who are already saying that
spark is being extinguished what do you
say the political commentators mostly
have no idea what's going on and don't
cure the may or may not be true well
that's my feeling the Occupy movements
in my opinion were just the fact that
the communities of solidarity and mutual
Association were created each of the
Occupy movement kind of spontaneously
developed their own self organized
society with the health centers at a
community kitchens pace spaces for
public discussion that's extremely
important especially in highly atomized
societies where people are separated
from one another by all sorts of
meetings including the media including
the Internet incidentally which does
tend to atomize and separate but this
was creating bonds associations the
conception that we can work together to
achieve something that's important and I
think that the kind of thing that
carries on the same with the Egyptian
movement of the Tunisian movement they
they have had successes the main
successes and I hope they're lasting
ones is too much far greatly broaden the
sphere the opportunities for freedom of
speech freedom of press and so on and
that's the way social movements develop
enough nothing happens unless the ground
is ready and preparing the ground is a
big part of it in an interview more than
a decade ago
now 2002 I think it was you said that
you believe the United States remains
and i'm quoting you the greatest country
in the world in some respects that
interview was in the New York Times it
was a they have a section of the
magazine section in which which meets
the media there's a media condition
called concision it means you have to
say something in two sentences between
commercials if you try to explain
anything has to be cut out that
interview actually went on for about 45
minutes what came through the filters
was a few sentences that sentence that
you quoted was part of a broader
discussion of the many dimensions of
freedom and I said there's plenty of
them they can't measure countries but in
some respects the u.s. is in fact the
freest country in the world a protection
freedom speech for example is upheld in
the United States beyond any place I
know of any place of Europe for example
and yes that's true I'm EJ let me ask
you one question about Barack Obama a
lot of liberals in America and many
people beyond the liberal community when
he was when he was a presidential
candidate they saw him as somebody who
embodied great hope for reform for
change did you ever share that emotion
know and just based on his record very
limited record as a senator and his
website in which he advertised himself
it was clear to me that he was going to
be at a very dangerous person and i gave
the reasons why and i haven't there's
some things he's done that did surprise
me but not much that what has surprised
me is his very harsh attack on civil
liberties that i didn't they anticipate
and I I frankly don't understand I don't
see what he gains from it and it's not
just prism and the things that are on
the front pages it's a for example he
and his Justice Department have pushed
court cases which they've won which
sharply expand
the already illegitimate notion of
assistance to terrorism it's a
legitimate because they're the ones who
designed what's terrorist but the Obama
administration extended it there was a
notion of the support for terrorism
which meant if you're in al-qaeda and I
give you a gun that support for
terrorism Obama extended it to speech so
that the case in question was a legal
rights group which was giving legal
advice to the PKK which is on terrorists
at Turkish group which Kurdish which is
on that the obamas terrorist list there
even them legal advice and if you read
the colloquy you know what the
government was presenting in the court
it could extend to me to people who meet
with and discuss activists and leaders
and what the government calls terrorist
groups that's a tremendous attack on
freedom of speech to questions about you
first question you're you're you're
always described rightly so as an
activist as a dissident as a militant
can you explain to me where that started
where did that come from what made you
the person you are go back a long way in
time was there a moment where I began
last three or four years old middle of
the depression depression is objectively
much worse than what's happening now but
people had come to the door and trying
to sell rags or sit with my mother in a
trolley car and see police beating up
women strikers outside a textile plant
lot of my family was unemployed working
class so how they lived and so on and by
the late 1930s I I was concerned and
childlike level with the rise of fascism
just pretty frightening that first
article I remember writing was I can
easily date it was februari 1939 right
after the fall of Barcelona
it was about fascism spreading in
Germany and Austria Czechoslovakia and
now Spain where's it going to end you
know that and goes on the opposition to
the British atrocities in Greece and
nineteen forty four nuclear weapons on
Iran doesn't stop yeah okay so that's
where you're coming from in a relatively
early book the responsibility of
intellectuals 1967 you wrote you you
talked about the question that
intellectuals and indeed non
intellectuals ask themselves what have I
done now after your long career in
activism in academia what's your answer
to your own question what have I done
not enough non Trotsky it's been
fascinating talking to you today thank
you very very much indeed yeah thank you